so dave chappelle won an emmy and his
acceptance speech was posted online he
basically said
[ __ ] up forever yes dude it was gangster
watch this really i didn't even watch it
yes
you want emmy's first uh special yeah
his most recent one
boy hey let me go this comes as a
complete surprise
what do you say it comes with a complete
surprise meaning like you want
or whatever i mean i read all the
reviews and they said
so many terrible things that's
i hope all you critics learn from this
this is a teachable moment
shut the [ __ ] up forever that's great
yeah let it go that's hard 100 percent
respect
all the way i like that all the way he's
doing shows
non-stop at his branch in ohio non-stop
i know
a girl from florida florida comic went
down there and uh
louis she said louis perform killed it
oh ck
yes yeah louis top five he said he's
just like
it's so fun out there he has it like
organic i was like man
i wonder how many people it is though
yeah i wonder how many people they let
in there
that's a great question yeah i don't
know but it looks outside yeah outside
there's so many companies
they've been calling it dave chappelle's
summer camp or something like that so
dope so dope
i respect that i love that man yeah shut
the [ __ ] up forever
yeah get a t-shirt that should be merch
shut the [ __ ] up forever forever
forever like but not for all the critics
that not only the writers but also the
fans too we're talking all that
[ __ ] everyone talking all that [ __ ]
non-stop
did you guys watch the entrance
yesterday i did not because let me guess
there's a whole political that people
win like you gotta vote we gotta do the
shot with it yeah shut the [ __ ] up man
forever
so because of covid they did something
new where everybody
was at their homes and they would send
somebody out in this type of outfit
with an emmy so they had a bunch of
extra ones if you won they would then
give you the emmy and then they'd leave
but some one of the contestants who
actually ended up losing
recorded this is how it looks like in
2020 when you lose an
emmy they just wave and they leave
shout out to romney that's a great show
that's a great show by the way great
show is it good
yeah really good show oh my girl one
zendaya
yep sunday over 21 right yes she's like
25.
if you got kids it's terrifying because
you're like was it like a scary
like they're doing it in high school and
doing drugs and
[ __ ] and just the dad's [ __ ] it's
crazy
it's so good a lot of dicks and a lot of
dicks and day is so good in it she's so
cute
she's doing a lot of ding-a-lings yeah
it's fantastic
i should have been on there i got a
little piece you were on uh
insecure yeah i was only secure he was
insecure he was also in creed yeah come
on man
that's definitely a little bit you got a
resume got a little credit you know
check his imbd
yeah you know we know you're out there
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this is from
a bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son